definitely we're seeing quite mixed
signals from our western alias and what
our president says especially when today
he asked
to share with this concrete intelligence
data that the united states are relying
on so people actually i don't observe
any sort of uh
extremely panic sentiment and key of uh
especially so shops are working normal
normally and yes definitely some people
are cautious and concerned especially
those who don't understand all these
nitty-gritty of diplomatic channel
diplomacy but on general level it is
more or less uh fine however all this uh
drastic evacuation of part of the
embassy staff of number of
member states of eu and some other
countries so definitely makes us a bit
nervous yeah
i was going to say that precisely is
that causing concern a number of
countries have urged their nationals to
get out especially britain the
netherlands um germany i think to the
united states and embassy staff being
withdrawn so that is bound to heighten
tension is it not
yes i think
this uh particular development uh
causing more tensions among ukrainians
than the actual data and reports and the
uh the rational thinking about the
possible russian invasion into ukraine
because speaking from terms of
negotiating i don't see
any rationale for russia to
to resort to full-scale invasion because
russia have so many leverages to play
with ukraine fragility uh more
sophisticated then to
resort to this uh a very um drastic way
of behavior and to provoke a big
condemnation and isolation from western
countries so you talk about russia
having leverage uh potentially of course
the americans came out just what 24
hours ago and said they said they
believed an invasion was
imminent uh has to be said that's not uh
that's being disputed by the french and
even russia following these talks today
seems to be putting
things on hold are you encouraged by
that perhaps
not actually i just can spot some sort
of uh differences in perception
perception of this russian threat and
signals coming from some european
countries and also from turkey because
they also referred to some intelligence
data from belarus and russia it's like
talking about that there is no actually
signs of possible invasion so
uh we definitely a bit confused with all
these mixed signals but uh definitely
doesn't mean that we are completely
relaxed we are getting prepared to all
possible scenarios however speaking
about possible
missile attack on kiev i don't see any
rational what goal putin will achieve
with that he will only get more anger
opposition and
resilience from ukrainians towards
russia so this would make the whole
geopolitical concept of
getting ukraine back into russian arms
completely impossible
what do you think of the next steps in
these efforts towards diplomacy and what
would you like to see happen
well my personal perception is that
russia successfully linked to the
dynamic in normandy formant and actually
the whole russian ukraine conflict
to the ongoing negotiations with the
united states and nato and possible
uh security arrangements in europe and
uh i think that this dynamic will
definitely impact
everything around conflict
between russia and ukraine
yet the
united states last night said the west
was more strengthened than ever and nato
was strong
yes actually uh i should uh say that we
see more coherence and uh uh coordinated
response from western countries uh to
russians actions and particularly i do
welcome the
response from the eu high representative
on foreign policy uh mr barrel apart
from uh uh the single voice of each
member states uh that russia intended to
get
so uh definitely in ukraine we hope that
this solidarity will prevail and this
channel diplomacy that a lot of european
leaders and uk leaders and also american
partners are doing at the moment they
will bear fruits in the immediate future
and russia has in its sights
we understand to destabilize
ukraine could that happen
uh yes russia actually
intends uh to get control over ukraine
uh for the long
term perspective not just immediate uh
effect therefore they will be playing
with all tools possible also within
infiltration of some
pro-russian forces and those who are
close to decision makers in ukraine
obviously supporting some pro-russian
parties um doing some cyber attacks and
all these
stuff also energy tools so as i said
they have plenty of different
instruments to play with and
it is up to ukrainian to our western
partners to be prepared to every
possible scenario and to offset these
risks before actually a disaster happens
just in one quick sentence is russia
then playing the long game and no
invasion in your view
is potentially imminent
i think they are losing losing patience
right now there are signs of that but
they won't win with a short brief attack
they would win more with the long-term
uh
sophisticated intellectual campaign
all right we were almost about the line
was almost about to break up then but we
heard you loud and clear thanks very
much indeed for your time on sky news
tonight good to see you thank you